- [Saquon:] Oh my gosh.
He's here.
- I heard he gives out his cell phone number
to everyone on the team.
- Who y'all talking about?
- It’s Caleb Williams.
Whoever wins the untalented show
gets to work with him next year.
- If he's a quarterback.
What am I gonna play?
[Announcer:] Welcome to the Gridiron
Heights Untalented Show.
Remember the worse you perform, the better.
- How do we look?
- Terrible.
- Perfect.
- Y'all, I'll be tap dancing the Griddy
to the tune of Mr. Bojangles.
- Two hands up. Two hands back.
Yes. Work that terrible Griddy.
- If your backup’s playing better than your starter...
you might have a quarterback controversy!
[crickets]
- Pew! Pew! Pew, pew!
Look how fun our culture is now!
Is this your card...inal?
-  Wait! Don't saw me in half, fam.
I'm still recovering.
Heyyo, fam. Not cool.
- Seito Caleb. Come to Vegas and I will train you in...
the Patriot Way! Wah-taaa!!
- [Levis puppet] I know. We’ll chuck it.
- [Willis puppet:] Holy s---.
That's really f--ing good.
- I can't do this anymore.
Please trade me.
- [Vrabel:] No, You're stuck here forever.
- Watch me 1, 2 step outta top draft pick.
- [Payton:] Stop freestyling!
You look better than the Chiefs, g--damnit.
You're up next.
- Unfortunately.
- Bear down, Chicago Bears!
With spare parts, put up a fight so grizzly...
of the Raid-er Naaaaaaation!
- Tyson, no! You're too good!
- If you ask your line for a clean pocket
and they start digging for lint--
- [Crowd:] Then you might have a quarterback
controversy!
- It's the Horsecollar Comedy Tour.